so by the way if you thought that all of
the censorship stuff was a little bit
too on the nose
well now we are in the realm of actual
book burn it
so over the last 24 hours antifa
demanded that powell's books in portland
shut down the store if they were if they
carried andy noe's book
on antifa so there are people in the
mainstream media pushing for this
i mean sarah zhang of the new york times
she was pushing for andy now to be
banned from twitter
why what was his grave crime he would go
to these antique rallies he would film
the nc for raleigh he'd put up the tape
of the antique for allies and then
he would identify with the photos the
people who'd been arrested at the nt for
allies
and when i say rallies i mean riots okay
but now
antifa showed up at uh at this portland
store called powell's books
and they demanded that the store stop
selling unmasked inside antifa's radical
plan to destroy democracy
that's the book by ansi the protest
forced the store to close early
pells then announced it would not carry
the book in its physical store though it
would still be
available for purchase online the book
will not be on our store shelves will
not promote it said powell's
that said will remain in our online
catalog we carry books that we find
anyway that we find anywhere from simply
distasteful or badly written to
excarable as well as those we treasure
we believe it is the work of bookselling
to do so
so uh here are some antifa protesters
outside powell's books explaining
that if they stopped the release of the
book that would be like stopping the
release of mein kampf here's some of
that footage
stop selling andy noe's book you're on
the board
[Applause]
yeah nothing nothing quite says
anti-fascism like in fascist fashion
closing a bookstore because someone was
writing about how terrible you are
by the way it's absolute cowardice for
pals to remove the book from the actual
shelves right that in and of itself
is absolute cowardice on an
extraordinary level i mean it is a
bookstore
if the idea here is that bookstores can
only carry books that the left agrees
with
and just like it is the idea here that
facebook is only allowed to allow posts
that facebook agrees with or twitter is
only allowed to allow posts that twitter
agrees with
and not only that if you are an outlet
that does not implement the same
standards as facebook or twitter does
with regard to its policing of content
that you can have your web service
removed
the culture of free speech is dead and
then once the culture of free speech is
dead
then it's just a question as to when the
law changes
right because the culture the law always
follows the culture the minute that the
culture of free speech dies in america
we're not very
it's really just the supreme court
standing between the left
and the destruction of actual legal free
speech in the country and we've had
articles
from people who are now going to be in
the biden administration talking openly
about why we need to adopt european
standards with regard to free speech
i.e bannon quote unquote hate speech
meaning stuff that the left doesn't like
very often hate speech encompasses
everything from actual horrible speech
to things like saying that a transgender
man is actually still a biological woman
right if it were not for the the barrier
of the first amendment
as interpreted by the supreme court
there is no question the left would be
pushing for this stuff incredibly
incredibly hard right now
under the on the basis of all of this is
a danger
all of this is incitement everything is
incitement remember this argument is old
okay just because of what happened at
the capitol does not mean that this is a
new argument it's been an old argument
that people were trying to shut down my
speeches at places like berkeley
requiring 600 police officers
because they were suggesting that me
standing in favor of free speech
was actually fascism right because words
are violence
words are violent this is literally what
they were chanting they're
they're chanting speech is violence the
punch and nazi movement
that that started a few years ago was
also completely reliant on the idea that
all of your fellow citizens are nazis if
they disagree with you
that is the direction the culture is
moving facts don't care about your
feelings and it's a fact that the ben
shapiro show is the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content